I think one of the things again I just
emphasize I'm not a lawyer but but keep
in mind that this is a civil proceeding
not a criminal proceeding so the
standards are very different in our
criminal justice system and I think that
that's that is a very big difference
that you don't have to have a
preponderance of guilt in the Civil uh
realm as you do in the criminal uh and
so that is a big big difference in the
criminal you have to have a unanimous
and I think the Civil is just a majority
so it's a very different standard uh it
is New York which isn't exactly the
friendliest of venues for president
Trump
um so again I think I'm reading this as
your or I'm listening to this and
evaluating as you're reading it out uh
it's never a good thing to have a
verdict against you I mean let's be
clear especially of this nature but I
think when it came to the big charge
that you're referring to uh that would
have that would have probably not gone
over very well on the campaign Trail
um and I think that's the bigger issue
is that Optics do matter in politics but
I think if you're president Trump right
now uh you're probably resting easy when
it came to the the charge of rape would
have stung a lot
I I I'm sure you're not implying that
the charge of sexual assault won't sting
um and I do get Sean you're you're
pointing out the differences between
criminal and civil and this is a civil
case no criminal charges have been
brought but this was a jury of six men
and three women who unanimously agreed
that it was more likely than not that he
had sexually abused someone I mean if
you were still his press secretary going
to the podium would you be trying to
defend him right now
well again I mean to to be blunt I mean
you're asking a a job of a press
secretary would be to defend your client
now that that's a so
from a from what your your question is
would you be trying to defend them
that's the job of of a press secretary
for a principal
um I I think so let's be honest about it
there's technicals there about how I
worded the question I mean I guess the
point is he's lost a trial it was a
civil one not a criminal one but there
were six men and three women who
unanimously agreed to this verdict I'll
put it a different way would you
struggle to work for him sir would you
resign instead of defending him if he
told you to do that oh look look Wilford
as I just said look I I I'm literally
hearing this as as you're reading it so
the first thing I would do is get all
the facts and I would try to understand
what the nature of it was I honestly as
an American that has heard about this
for a while wasn't even aware that this
was one of the charges that was
available so I didn't even know that I I
my understanding from the American Media
with this was entirely uh a case about
rape uh I didn't know that this was a
charge that was even available to the
jury uh so I would be asking lawyers
what this means
um what the difference between uh the
two charges were in terms of uh what the
the
the the legal ramifications were and
what the judge's orders were but I mean
the first thing would be to do exactly
what I'm doing now which is to
understand the nature of the law because
I don't know it and I'm hearing it as
you're putting it out
okay I mean it's sexual assault uh and
it's five million dollars of Damages so
so I don't know uh exactly again I I
think I've made clear it is never a good
thing so I just want to be clear on that
I'm not in any way trying to dismiss the
severity of a chart there is a
difference in our Judicial System
between civil and criminal I am not a
lawyer I don't know the difference in
the nature between them you're asking me
what I would do and my answer to you
would be that I would try to understand
the difference between the two in terms
of the legality of it before I would
answer the question but from from an
optic standpoint of course it doesn't
look good yeah I mean they're both
illegal and they're both immoral and
they're both wrong but anyway let's just
switch focus a little bit because I'm
interested uh in how you think
all of this plays
um because clearly anything seems to
bounce off him of late and and how do
you think leading up to this case it was
being framed as a Witch Hunt perhaps at
times against him does the does the
verdict uh change that significantly now
do you think did he need to be cleared
for for this to continue down the path
of many framing this is political
motivations or do you still believe that
there are political motivations
well I think as you said at the outset I
mean the president Trump has been over
not just the last couple of years but
frankly the last couple decades been
attacked politically for several
different things and it's always bounced
off of them so I don't know that this
will have any difference on them uh
we'll have to wait and see but I also
think that the way that the district
attorney went after president Trump
several weeks ago has tainted the
process against him he has been able to
say going forward you see these folks
are after me writ large
um and I think that defense
because of the nature of the way that
the district attorney in New York went
after president Trump I think that that
might taint the entire system going
forward and make his his claim that this
is quote a political Witch Hunt have a
lot more resonance
but would you personally reject that
given that we've reached a point where
this so I'm not trying to be tricky here
I'm generally just thinking of that is
interested that we've now reached a
point where this was a unanimous
decision by nine members of a jury so so
even if the motivations to get to the
point of a court case if that's what
you're saying have political motivations
we've got nine members of a jury who
unanimously have decided something here
now nine members of a civil case made a
decision and again as I stated at the
outset I'm not a lawyer and I'm hearing
it from you at the time I I don't make
decisions like that and I would caution
anybody who is being asked a question
like this to actually get the facts and
understand them before they make it
because you've used words like illegal
and it's not a court of law it's a civil
case and so that's my point is that when
you throw around words like that and
mislead audiences that's part of the
problem so what I would urge people to
do is to get facts and then make a
decision before they make snap decisions
about their interpretation of what was
what was said or done or or decided and
that's what I will do as a citizen